All right, we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. this
is funny.
Um, we have very often heard from a guy that
I know as the San Antonio troll and one of
the things that he does frequently is call
in and attack me either for the position I
took in a story I didn't actually cover.
He'll say, David, how dare you say X, Y,Z
? And it's like about a story I never even
covered.
Or he likes to call in and say, David, you
will never ever cover this story because it
conflicts with this narrative or that narrative
that you're trying to perpetuate.
In this case.
Here's the San Antonio troll telling me I
will never, ever, ever cover the incident
that took place yesterday in Jersey city of
a black, a former black Israelite, shooting
up a kosher a supermarket.
That story you might remember was covered
20 minutes ago on today's program.
Take a listen.
Hey Pacman.
I know that, um, you know, the second you
end your show early in the morning, um, on
the afternoon you put yourself on a bunch
of different medications that you got from
your psychiatrist.
You fall asleep early and then you have a
news.
I know you probably your face probably lit
up when you saw there was a shooting in New
Jersey.
Bad news.
It wasn't a white person.
So leave it alone.
Don't pitch the story.
Um, it doesn't matter even if it works.
Use that were the unfortunate victims.
Um, but just don't touch it.
Saving you time, man.
It wasn't a white person.
So anyways,
that was weird.
I don't know if that was like another person
in the background.
There was a weird kind of sound there.
Of course I did cover the story and listened
it.
This is not a program that, uh, ignore stories
because they don't fit a particular narrative.
I do, you know, we all have our biases.
I do the best I can to always examine what
the facts are and to integrate those facts
into my broader assessment or position or
worldview.
I didn't ignore the story.
I covered that story.
It was an antisemitic incident.
Uh, we talked about black Israelites, we talked
about all of the different elements surrounding
this and uh, sorry to disappoint you, San
Antonio troll.
But the story has been covered already on
today's bonus show.
We will talk about Nikki Haley's statement
that the Confederate flag, uh, could not be
taken down in South Carolina in today's outrage
culture.
What on earth is she talking about?
We will talk about yet another one of these
instances where a big corporation puts people's
lives at risk.
People actually die, and then they pay a tiny,
tiny fine to regulators or to the government,
and there's really no consequences that actually
seem like they would dissuade corporations
from engaging in the exact same type of behavior.
Again, in this particular case, we're going
to talk about Boeing on the bonus show and
the seven 37 max.
Uh, and then also there is a lawsuit which
claims that sat and act scores act tests act
tests are illegal in California admissions.
Why?
I will tell you on the bonus show two ways
to get instant access,
become a member@joinpacmandotcomorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman job, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].